[Music]
oh smitty
i think i'll have a martini i'm meeting
my sister for lunch today
i had a sister but when the tornado came
we'd already boarded up the cellar door
she hung onto the pickup as long as she
could
we found her on top of the school
anyway jenny had an accident when we
were children i mean nothing funny like
your family
you know some people could have gotten
very bitter but
not chin no she's a brave girl just
soldiers on as if nothing happened stop
staring at me what are you all looking
at
that freak whose left leg is
three-eighths of an inch shorter than
the right
shin please if they were looking at
anyone it was me
my boob popped out before you got here
apparently it stayed out for quite some
time
i only realized it when smitty lifted it
to get his tip
at least your boob doesn't need to wear
an orthotic
well um listen jim
you know how i've been supporting you
for all these years
if you can call 300 000 a month support
for the sake of argument let's say we
can
now that stanley and i are getting a
divorce i'm afraid that i won't be able
to send you those checks anymore
i'm sorry say that again i didn't hear
you because one of my legs is shorter
than the other
you're such a pessimist gin why not say
one of my legs is freakishly long
karen if you think you're gonna cut me
off think again
since we both know how i ended up like
this it was an
accident was it june please stop
begging you know i was ordering jim
please
please you have to forgive me i have no
other choice the question is can you
forgive yourself for casting me out
after leaving me so hideously deformed
unable to dance to skip
to read
why can't you read oh i don't wanna
you